et pour en parler nous sommes avec alain
accords vaise conseiller en stratégie
internationale bonsoir alain cordesse
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors on l'a vu aujourd'hui réunion au
sommet de la commission conjointe sur le
nucléaire iranien quel est l'objectif
concrètement de cette réunion alors
d'abord c'est pas une réunion au sommet
comme vous venez de le dire mais c'est
une réunion au niveau des directeurs
politiques des des puissances qui sont
représentés à bienne c'est à dire qui
n'est pas le ministre des affaires
étrangères ce sont des soies le vice
ministre abass arachi que je connais
bien d'ailleurs pour l'avoir rencontrée
nous deux fois et notamment une fois où
était de passage à paris
est ce que je peux dire à son sujet à
l'époque c'est à dire il ya un an ou un
an et demi il nous avait dit absolument
la même chose que ce qui le répète
c'était que l'iran était prêt à revenir
sur les décisions qu'ils avaient prise
de sortir de l'accord puisque il était
le seul à le respecter
les états unis avaient déchiré cet
accord international
je rappelle que c'était entérinée par
une résolution des nations unies et les
autres puissances restantes elles
faisait ce qu'elle pouvait pour essayer
de s'entendre avec l'iran mais elles
n'ont rien fait l'iran devait récolter
le fruit d' c'était d'avoir de la
signature de cet accord pour son
économie
vendre son pétrole développer ses
activités économiques avec l'ensemble
des pays du monde et les américains
ayant rompu cet accord non seulement ils
empêchent l'iran donc de bénéficier des
avantages d'avoir signé l'accord mais en
outre ils font des pressions sur tous
les autres pays de la planète notamment
les pays européens notamment la france
qui a d'énormes intérêts économiques en
iran de faire une quelconque transaction
moi j'ai eu des contacts avec les
grandes sociétés françaises et même des
moyennes et petites qui voulaient
investir en iran et les grands dans tout
comme mon tout dit mais on ne peut pas
bouger le petit doigt à cause des états
unis car dès qu'on fera quelque chose en
direction de l'iran nous seront
sanctionnés par les états unis
alors pour revenir à cet accord que vous
avez très bien décrit dans votre
reportage là juste avant effectivement
ou des données toutes les les paramètres
de cet accord est ce qu il en reste
aujourd'hui de cet accord mais il en
reste que l'un ce texte que les
européens ont voulu ont mis sur pied
c'est un steak c'est à dire une chambre
de compensation pour essayer de
continuer à faire du commerce avec
l'iran pour les européens en marge des
restrictions des états unis c'est à dire
ça pourrait être dans une une monnaie en
euros
bon il ya veille avait ce set ce
dispositif financier et économique pour
poursuivre mais pour le moment aucune
transaction n'a été fait aucune aucun
contrat n'a été signé avec l'iran donc
on comprend qu'au bout d'un an l'iran à
des mais nous sommes les seuls à
respecter l'accord donc maintenant nous
nous commençons degré par degré à sortir
des
des règles qui avait été établi
néanmoins les iraniens ont répété tout
dernièrement et je crois encore
aujourd'hui à bassar acquis que rien
n'est irréversible et que si il pouvait
retrouver un bénéfice c'est à dire
vendre du pétrole déjà parce que les
états unis il voudrait qu'il ne puisse
pas vendre son pétrole
je viens danser sanctions c'est à cause
des sanctions ils peuvent plus rien
faire en fait ne peuvent plus rien
sortir de leur pays que ce soit du
pétrole ou autre chose
donc il ya une possibilité de
négociation à mon avis est que ces hauts
diplomates qui discutent actuellement
trouve un allègement pour l'iran par
exemple qu'ils puissent vendre son
pétrole à telle ou telle puissance
parties prenantes à l'accord ou autre
chose et à ce moment-là l'iran l'iran
est prêt à faire marche arrière sur les
sorties qu'il a fait 2 de l'accord
notamment sur le l'enrichissement de
l'uranium
alors à terme l'absence de conciliation
peut mener au rétablissement par le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu de toutes
les sanctions qui avaient été levés dans
le cadre de l'accord de vienne mais on
suppose que c'est pas l'objectif non
c'est pas l'objectif je pense que
l'objectif de cette réunion c'est de
trouver un des failles dans le système
américain pour que l'on puisse donner
des avantages économiques à l'iran qui
souffrent énormément bien entendu de ces
sanctions
la population souffre énormément en fait
les états unis auraient voulu que
souffrant de sur le plan économique la
population se soulève pour renverser le
régime
elle a vu que c'était quelque chose qui
ne fonctionnait pas donc je pense que
les etats unis ont pu revenir à une
position plus plus raisonnable sur cette
affaire-là
et on peut essayer effectivement de
trouver des mesures qui permettent à
l'iran de commercer un peu n'est pas
qu'on va ouvrir complètement les choses
mais a levé une partie des sanctions de
façon que des opérations commerciales se
déroule et à ce moment-là l'iran est
prêt à revenir sur
le dépasser le seuil des 300 kilos
d'uranium enrichi enfin sur les
différentes mesures qui ont été
expliquées dans votre reportage qui
était très bien à cet égard l'iran a
déjà évoqué le nucléaire en réponse aux
menaces de donald trump
lavrov a qualifié cette réunion de
chance pour arrêter l'escaladé avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard
existe-t-il aujourd'hui une réelle
menace militaire
oui il existe une réelle menace
militaire mais j'ajoute aussitôt que je
ne pense pas qu'il y aura la guerre
parce que il ya une menace militaire
parce qu'il ya des forces en présence
les forces américaines bien sûr présente
dans le moyen-orient mais également
depuis les etats unis
et puis il ya un dispositif militaire
iranien très puissant à la fois en iran
et puis dans ces pays
les pays alliés irak syrie au yémen et
au liban et et au donc il ya un
dispositif militaire qui pourrait
permettre l'enclenchement d'un confit
mais je ne crois pas qu'il y aura un
conflit parce que ya pas eu de conflit
mondial depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale à cause de la bombe atomique
l'iran n'a pas la bombe atomique
il assurait d'ailleurs qu'il ne voulait
pas avoir la bombe que c'était contraire
à ses principes mais il a des moyens de
dissuasion d'adeptes d'attac qui sont
largement équivalent à une bombe
atomique parce que les états unis et
israël savent que s'ils attaquent et
l'iran les représailles que l'iran
pourrait effectuer dans la région sur
sur israël et pas seulement lui mais ses
alliés sur les forces américaines
présentes ce serait insupportable
terrible pour donc je pense que donald
points moi c'est mon secret espoir c'est
que quand il sera réélu car je pense
qu'il sera réélu il ya déjà des
indications qui montrent que il en a
assez de ces guerres permanentes au
moyen-orient et qu'il a bien compris que
continuer cette
hostilité permanente contre l'iran ne
débouchera sur rien et qu'il changera
d'attitude et à partir du mois de
novembre de l'année prochaine
son deuxième mandat sera mon avis très
différent du premier et j'espère que
l'on pourra déboucher vers un apaisement
il aura un discours beaucoup plus
conciliant envers l'iran c'est ce que
vous voulez je pense qu'il aura un
discours plus conciliant plus réaliste
il est réaliste il sait il sait que
l'iran est une grande puissance savez
quand ils ont reproché à l'iran de
développer des missiles balistiques
ensuite d'avoir une influence sur de
nombreux pays de la région du
moyen-orient mais c'est dire on veut pas
que l'iran soit l'iran l'iran bien sûr
il se défend donc qu'il a aujourd'hui
mis au point un système de défense très
puissant c'est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure qui est une sorte de
dissuasion d' attaques contre lui
et puis deuxièmement il a des alliés
parce qu'il ya des gens qui sont
favorables à l'iran et c'est dans la
nature de la géographie et de la
géopolitique et donc on peut pas être
contre ça merci beaucoup alain corvez je
rappelle que vous êtes conseiller en
stratégie internationale